- Kal and I mentioned our
shared love about our space,
but it doesn't end there people,
we have many other things
we are passionate about.
So it's time to come clean about our
♪ Obsessions ♪
(soft music)
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughing)
That's right, y'all it's
time to own our obsessions.
I'll hit this button and a
topic will be selected by our
super random supercomputer.
And then the person obsessed
with the topic will own up and
sell us on whatever it is they love.
So here we go.
Are you ready?
- I'm ready.
- Okay, let's start with Kal.
It's time for
♪ Obsession baby yeah ♪
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughing)
- Wait, wait
- Okay
- This is kind of creepy.
- Well nuns all right.
- Okay
- Now, first of all, sister act of course.
- Sister acts
- Right I got it
- Both of them
- But I am so fascinated and
obsessed with nuns because they
have taken a vow and an oath and
they've got all these rules.
- Yeah
- They're serving a higher power
and they're supposed to serve
as like I think a moral
compass or guide to you.
You call them sister
- It's like a lot of weight
- The dress, all of it, but you see them.
I live in New York city
and you see them walking down the street.
I mean, in this moral-less, is that a word
- I don't know
- just this 24, 7 city
where anything is possible.
And here are these, moral women
just walking through past the drunk guy
- Just doing it
- and the guy smoking his weed
- And not judging
- Just doing that thing.
- That's the thing, although
I feel like they do judge,
but you have to go to them
to ask for the judgment and
forgiveness, but it's the whole
package that I'm just like,
I am fascinated by nuns.
- Well they are human
so they are let a bit of judgment.
- Exactly
- Oh, okay It's my turn.
Here's one of my
♪ Obsessions ♪
(soft music)
(Kelly laughing)
Let's turn
- Oh
- Oh, oh
- Go ahead go ahead
- It's a beautiful thing ear cleaning.
It feels so good and I know
you're not supposed to do it
and you're not supposed to get in there.
Whatever doctors I do it.
I do it and it so good and I love
especially when you get out of the shower,
how are you not supposed to
put a Q-tip in there and dry it all up?
It's all squishy.
It's sounding like there's water.
So you've got to clean it
out and it feels so good.
- It feels good, It feels good.
- It feels good.
- you've already won me over by the way.
- Okay
- I'm a big personal hygiene person.
- Okay me too
- So you've described it perfectly.
- yes
- all the things I want to avoid.
- Yes
- Have you done like ear candling
and is it a real thing.
- Absolutely
- okay
- Oh my God my favorite thing is
I'm so weird is to ear candle
And then you open it up
and you're like what?
I'm like all this gunk
I know you say, Ooh,
and it's like a treasure hunt.
(Kal laughing)
It's like a treasure hunt.
I'm so excited about
what's going to be in it.
I love it.
(audience cheering)
Do you ear candle?
- I've never handled because
I keep reading different-
- You not supposed to do it too much
- Okay alright
- Like maybe every six months or so
I'm not a doctor maybe look that up, but,
- You've done your own research
- Yeah I've done my own research
and I think it's every six months,
any more than that too
much, but it's so cool.
I'm obsessed anyway.
- That's cool you've won me
over on that I'll agree with you
- You're welcome for your new obsession.
- Thank you
- Next one for Kal.
- All right
♪ Obsessions ♪
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh
- Alright now.
- I love sweet pickle.
- I am going to preface this by saying
that I tell everybody
that I won master chef.
When in reality, I only
want one challenge on
one episode of celebrity master chef.
- Okay
- That's how arrogant I am
about my very limited cooking experience.
That said,
what I love about sweet pickles is
it's a contrast to most
sandwiches, which are savory.
So you've got the savory,
you've got whatever you're putting on it.
- Oh my god my mouth is watering.
- You put a little mustard, a little Mayo,
- Yes
- all of that on a nice,
nice, crunchy bread
- Maybe some chips make
it crunchy whatever
- exactly I like where
you're going with this.
- Get crazy get crazy
- This is where the pickles come in.
The crunch of the pickle
against something soft
and it's sweet.
So it's coupled really nicely.
- I love sweet pickles.
I will grab a jar of sweet
pickles at 8:00 PM, sir.
- Yes
- And just be like,
- or green olives
I like this.
- Yeah
- All right Okay.
- Okay, let's do another one of my,
♪ Obsessions ♪
(soft music)
(Kelly laughing)
I love you Dylan
Okay,
oh, have you played?
You have an Oculus?
- No.
- Okay okay.
- I don't know what this is at all
- It's VR it's virtual reality.
- Yeah yeah
- And it's a game that I
totally got for our kids.
And mommy uses it more
(Kal laughing)
There is a game on there and it's like,
you have Lightsabers.
Okay.
- okay
- Hmm. It's so cool.
And, you're like, that was my Lightsaber.
And you get to like,
basically it's dancing,
it's called Beat Saber and
you chop these like blocks,
but you have to do in certain orders.
- okay
- And it's like to a beat and
they've got music playing.
And I am just like at a
rave when it's happening.
- That's awesome
- And my children are like
watching me, like, mommy,
can I play? Not your turn yet.
(Kal laughing)
it's literally I can get
lost in it for hours.
It's so fun.
And you sweat, you're behind off
- It sounds like that was my
question is it aggressive like
- It gets intense. They
have like beginner,
- yeah
- like that's so easy,
but then you get to the
advanced and it's so fun.
And it comes at you so fast.
All these little things
you have to chop with your Lightsabers.
It's so fun.
I want to somehow be able to
play Lightsaber on this show
with someone that comes on,
- Yeah
- cause I think it'd be really fun
- Well, I'll tell you right now,
I'm gonna get one
- okay
- The passion with which you
just took me into the game
- You're going to love it,
You're going to love it.
- With what you just said
- And they have great music
and now a lot of artists are
doing their music with it.
- yeah
- So you'll get like tons.
- It's really cool
- it's like when garage
band came out, you know,
- yeah
- and they had they had some cool songs,
but then they all of a
sudden started getting like a
plethora of more.
- yeah
- It was awesome.
Anyway, I love Beat Saber.
- All right Beat Saber right on
- It's really fun.
And that covers our
♪ obsession ♪
(soft music)